have you ever met Matt I was gonna do so
and I'm so grateful to both of you
you've given me so much joy over my
lifetime so I like over my lifetime I
make it sound a thousand years old but
like I was so excited to come today and
be sandwiched by you
[Applause]
everybody thinks everybody knows each
other like you got to cut some kind of
celebrity barbecue weekly or something
yeah I don't know anyone
you and I are actually gonna be taking
joey tribianni down and a friend's game
are you ready well we can be nice to him
now though cuz you know then we'll kick
his ass play we're not gonna be nice
about ability but then you got there
okay you got there no I love you loved
friends though right oh yeah yeah how
about you guys I mean
but today's show is a love letter to New
York and you just moved there right yes
I loved it so much it is my heart no I
grew up in North Carolina I will not
come out our family live in Nashville
yeah we have family a Nashville and
Raleigh and in Granite Falls yeah yeah I
didn't know that but um to get this job
and to get it was always like a Holy
Grail you know to get a job that
wonderful in New York City and now I
just said have a tiny little balcony and
you know overlooks an avenue and I don't
see your apartment does it look like
Monica or Joey's like this table here
sometimes and here sometimes here
sometimes and I love it have you shopped
for apartments did you shop for me did
you find I did it all on street easy
have you ever used that Street II know
if I was here so I wasn't in New York I
had to like ask my friends we do go to
this open house on Wednesday but yeah
tell my thumbs fell off that's how I
found my little apartment and then it
was all IKEA and like Amazon I built my
bed and my dresser yeah you should never
you can really tell your true friends
are I don't think you should build
furniture like that with loved ones yeah
I feel like it ends poorly I mean
because they always say like it's that
little cartoon that like it's like this
is a two-person job which I feel is
angry at single people so I don't I do
not accept so deep Matt do you have a
story place that you're crazy about like
a Nike or anything like that you know
we're doing friends if we weren't
working we were like at a photo shoot or
doing press for the show or it was
really consuming so when that ended I
kind of said I need to go out and
re-engage with the world and I find
discovered this place called Target
[Applause]
you could get Bologna and motor oil and
pillows you can get everything and
here's the thing about target though
it's like you know Allison wondering on
the rabbit hole you just go down B can I
go in for a spatula and I come out with
500 drop my dome that's my that Whole
Foods was whole paycheck I got a little
check like Target there's always
something here again yeah I'm in target
anonymous now but I have to talk to you
about this because I completely stormed
into your dressing room because you kept
me up till 1:30 in the morning last
night I was so excited to see prodigal
son and I then you I heard you were
coming honestly I was like kind of been
dying to watch this for so long I was
like I'll just watch one episode just so
I know seven episodes later I'm in my
bed and my husband is snoring and I'm
like I just have to know if and I don't
want to run it so I'm not gonna say it
I'm not gonna say that I had to know
something and they kept teasing you and
I had to keep watching and it's so good
no much it's the highest-rated new show
right now
I don't know if you've seen it yet it's
sort of it's a show that asks a question
what if Hannibal Lecter were your father
my husband
sorry your husband Michael Sheen plays
that character he's my husband and he
got carted off to Hannibal Lecter land
and he might secretly be psycho like
just a very good actor like who all
that's not anger and Tom Payne from
Walking Dead yes our son all groan yeah
and now he's the profiler trying to
atone for the sins of his father yeah
it's got the family shows up like heart
and humor but it's got enough horror -
yeah keep you awake amber - even like
the serial killer kind of humors funny
and I'm laughing at it I'm like that's
not funny
laughter god I love it
I am very excited for this show for you
it's like I mean you're just going from
one hit show to the next so there you go
University or well subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going